oder gaspreisdeckel wie auch immer man
ist denn nennen mag was ist denn jetzt
der Stand der Dinge
da stand der Dinge ist dass man sich gar
nicht mal einig ist wie ist denn heißen
soll das was hier dann geboren wird ob
es ein Deckel überhaupt wird ob es ein
flexibler Deckel wird ob es eine Bremse
wirkt all das ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
völlig offen die Staats- und
Regierungschefs die sitzen jetzt bei
einem Dinner zusammen seit 21 Uhr reden
weiter über die Energiekrise und die
Lösungen aber die Fronten sind durchaus
verhärtet in Deutschland hat ja im
Vorfeld schon mehrfach klar gemacht dass
es kein festen Deckel möchte der Kanzler
hat hier heute erklärt dass er Angst hat
dass dann die LNG Schiffe mit dem Gas
einfach woanders hinfahren denn der
gasdeckel könnte dazu führen dass Europa
dann als Markt nicht mehr attraktiv ist
für die Gaslieferanten wäre wohin gegen
ja andere Länder gerade aus dem Süden
Europas genau das auch schon eine ganze
Weile fordern also ein fixen Preis für
Gas eine Obergrenze da ist aber
eigentlich keine Einigung in Sicht sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass da wirklich heute
substanziell was kommt da ist man
einfach miteinander verärgert
gegeneinander verärgert und ich glaube
nicht dass das eine Lösung ist die hier
präsentiert wird schon eher das mit den
gemeinsamen Gaseinkauf den man EU-weit
ja regeln könnte zumindest in Teilen
aber kein Deckel das ist eben beim Thema
Energie gibt es da den ja den Ärger auch
ungewöhnlich harte Worte ja letztendlich
was würden Sie denn sagen so allgemein
ist man sich in dieser großen Krise denn
doch auch unabhängig jetzt von der
Energie eher einig oder ist das jetzt so
ein Punkt wo man sagt oh das das könnte
dann wirklich auch dazu führen dass es
noch mehr Ärger gibt und mehr
Uneinigkeit
die Frage ist wie man darauf blickt der
französische Staatspräsident macron hat
Deutschland hier ja als isoliert
beschrieben das war nicht gerade sehr
nett aber auf der anderen Seite gehört
klappern auch zum Geschäft dazu und wenn
man sich hier so ein bisschen umhört
dann sagen doch einige dass das
kalkuliert war dass man eben versucht
Deutschland dazu zu bewegen auch mehr
Geld auszugeben für mögliche europäische
entlastungspakete auch für ja die
Wirtschaft in Europa zu stärken und dass
das eben auch eine ganze Menge Taktik
immer bei solchen EU-Gipfeln damit im
Spiel ist ob ein Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz der sich ja auch an anderen
Stellen schon durch seine norddeutsche
Sturheit durchaus ausgezeichnet hat
davon wirklich beeindrucken lässt bei
diesem Gipfel das glaube ich nicht da
habe ich so meine Zweifel denn man muss
ja auch immer überlegen wenn Deutschland
jetzt schon zu diesem Zeitpunkt auch
dieser Krise noch mehr Geld auf den
Tisch legen würde auf den Tisch auch in
Brüssel die Frage ist was hat man dann
eigentlich noch übrig wenn es im Winter
dann noch härter kommen sollte insofern
ist das etwas was hier die Stimmung
zumindest im Vorfeld sicher nicht
befördert hat aber danach gab es ja auch
ein gemeinsames Treffen zwischen Scholz
und macron da sahen die Bilder und die
Blicke dann doch etwas freundlicher aus
und es gibt hier eigentlich nur eine
Person wo die meisten dann auch mit
denen man spricht sagen da ist auch die
Stimmung etwas frostiger das ist dann
doch auch der ungarische
Ministerpräsident Viktor Orban der ja
auch selbst bei dem gemeinsamen
Gaseinkauf ein bisschen der
Spielverderber ist und der EU
vorgehalten hat dass das ja schon mal
schief gegangen sei mit dem gemeinsamen
Einkauf bei den corona-impfstoffen das
habe zu lange gedauert dass sei sehr
teuer gewesen und deswegen ist Ungarn
auch bei diesem Thema nicht wirklich
imused insofern wird es sicher nicht
einfach wie immer dass alle am Ende da
etwas unterschreiben aber es ist
zumindest so dass man sagen kann manches
von dem was im Vorfeld gesagt hat ist
dann am Tisch wenn dann miteinander
gesprochen wird vielleicht doch nicht
mehr ganz so wild sind wir gespannt
vielen Dank Marc Steinhäuser für diese
aktuellen Informationen aus Brüssel und
ich würde diesen Eindruck würde ich ganz
gerne mal direkt mit Rolf-Dieter Krause
besprechen weil sie haben natürlich ganz
viele EU-Gipfel beobachtet und
kommentiert ist das so ein übliches
Verfahren oder ist das heute doch ein
bisschen noch mal was schärferes wenn
Frankreich sagt in Deutschland ist
isoliert erstens was die Leute vor den
Kameras sagen ist das eine und was sie
miteinander besprechen hinter
verschlossenen Türen ist das andere und
das ist oft sehr anders als das was sie
vorher für die Öffentlichkeit gesagt
haben das muss man immer wissen in der
Tat da wird wieder versucht eine Drucker
loskulisse aufzubauen am Ende soll
Deutschland das Portemonnaie aufmachen
das ist das alte Spiel in in Europa
erinnern sich mal an die corona-zeit was
dafür eigentlich ja alle in ganz Europa
war bis Frau Merkel dann eingeknickt ist
und zugestimmt hat dass Europa was einen
wie finde historischer Sündenfall war
aber
ganz Europa die EU Schulden aufnehmen
darf und dann gleich in der Höhe von von
der dreiviertel Billionen Euro
zum Teil ist ja noch hoffentlich noch
nicht mal aufgenommen als denn da müssen
wir und ja Zinsen zahlen aber der die
Frage das ist ist der Versuch wieder
umzuverteilen das war schon als Scholz
sein doppelwurms ankündigte da haben
viele in Europa schon schon gemockert
und haben gesagt wir hätten gern was
davon ab und und das versuchen sie halt
es gibt ein ein hinter dem Ganzen ein
ganz reales Problem es gibt verschiedene
Interessen es gibt Länder in Europa die
wollen vor allem den Gaspreis möglichst
senken und es gibt andere die machen
sich große Sorgen um ihre
Versorgungssicherheit aus Deutschland
übrigens nicht isoliert da gibt es eine
ganze Reihe von der Holland Bulgarien
noch ein paar andere
so und Deutschland ist von dieser
versorgungsproblematik besonders
betroffen weil wir bei uns der Anteil
russischen Gases besonders hoch war so
und das müssen wir ersetzen und wir
haben in ganz Europa jetzt die Lage dass
wir einen Bedarf an Energie haben dem
kein entsprechendes Angebot
gegenübersteht das führt zu hören
Preisen auf die Dauer gibt es gegen
höhere Preise nur ein Mittel entweder
umschichten zu erneuern Energien oder
sparen sparen sparen und wahrscheinlich
geht kurzfristig nur das letztere aber
bleiben wir mal bei dieser Frage was das
für ein Signal ist auch wenn sie sagen
es ist vor den Kamera wird anders
geredet als dann im Hintergrund vor
seiner was finden sie denn was das für
ein Signal da heute ist wenn man in so
einer starken Krise wo Menschen hier
wirklich auf Europa und auf die einige
EU setzen sehen Deutschland und
Frankreich haben da Zoff miteinander
naja erstmal ist es ja auch okay anderer
Meinung zu sein das ist ja auch Teil des
demokratischen Spiels aber auch das
demokratischen Wettbewerbs und es ist
auch ein Stück weit
von Deutschland auch hervorgerufen
worden also wenn man sieht wir haben den
200 Milliarden den doppelwumms sozusagen
verkündet er war weitestgehend nicht
abgestimmt und natürlich haben andere
Mitgliedstaaten auch große Pakete
geschnürt die auch proportional ähnlich
waren wie die Deutschen aber man darf
natürlich nicht vergessen dass
Deutschland einerseits eine sehr sehr
große Verantwortung hat als Staat in der
Mitte Europas als größter Profiteur des
Binnenmarktes und dass wir natürlich da
auch aufgrund unserer Größe diese 200
Milliarden Mast das hat massive
Auswirkungen auf den Binnenmarkt und das
kann man auch nicht kleinreden wenn wir
jetzt hier unsere Wirtschaft unsere
Industrie stützen
wird das Auswirkungen haben auch auf
andere Länder auch auf andere Industrien
und darum kann ich schon auch Geld
aufgenommen aber zum Teil ja auch nur um
den Konsum zu stützen also sozusagen
diese Frage das ist ja auch alles noch
zumindest in Deutschland noch sehr
unklar welche Form das jetzt in der Tat
haben wird aber in dem Moment wo wir
sozusagen auch die Unternehmen Stützen
hat das Auswirkungen auf dem Binnenmarkt
darum haben wir ja auch die Diskussion
über das Beihilferecht jetzt ob der die
200 Milliarden dann auch zulässig sind
und sowas muss man sowas kann man machen
aber das muss man vorher diskutieren das
muss man abstimmen und da muss man auch
transparent sein und ich glaube das war
ein großer Fehler dass Deutschland das
nicht gemacht hat und da hätte ich auch
mehr von der Bundesregierung erwartet
also dass sie sagen dieses diese 200
diesen doppelwurms hätte man eben auf
europäischer Ebene abstimmen müssen nein
ich meine jetzt nicht im Sinne von
verhandeln aber man hätte sich mit
seinen Partnern vorabstimmen und das
auch vielleicht koordinieren müssen oder
vielleicht auch zumindest wir haben uns
doch auch allein gemacht die anderen
aber es macht einen Unterschied ob wir
200 Milliarden auf dem Tisch legen wie
Deutschland oder 40 Milliarden um
Haushalte zu stützen wie die Niederlande
das muss man auch wesentlich kleiner als
Deutschland Herr pappke wie sehen Sie
das wenn halt eben oder wie wie
betrachten Sie das jetzt was heute ein
Brüssel ist was man sagt da ist ein
bisschen knarrt und es geht auch vor
allen Dingen Ärger über die sind
doppelwumms sagen sie das ist das gute
Recht das muss jedes Land für sich also
ich bin da ganz Bayern Krause das ist
der übliche Versuch an die PIN-Nummer
der deutschen Kreditkarte zu kommen das
geht letztlich ums Geld und ich kann
auch den den Einwand nicht nicht
nachvollziehen Deutschland hätte dieses
diesen doppelwumms bleiben wir mal bei
diesem etwas schrägen Begriff
im Vorhinein abstimmen müssen wie das
ausgestaltet wird ist ja auch auf der
nationalen Ebene noch völlig offen das
weiß ja bisher noch niemand und
völlig richtig ist auch der Hinweis dass
es um uns herum ja zum Teil schon seit
Monaten in Frankreich schon seit Mitte
des Jahres eine strompreisbremse und
eine
gaspreisbremse gibt und so französischen
Freunde sind nicht im Traum auf die Idee
gekommen dass mal Beihilfe rechtlich
anzumelden oder gar mit Deutschland
abzustimmen also dass Deutschland jetzt
seine nationalen Interessen vertritt ist
in allen anderen Ländern der
Europäischen Union selbstverständlich
und ich finde wir sollten gar nicht erst
anfangen uns da irgendein schlechtes
Gewissen einreden zu lassen wer redet in
dem ein schlechtes Gewissen ein naja es
ging ja gerade schon los hätte hätte
Deutschland das nicht vorher abstimmen
müssen und das ist ja auch ein Teil der
Strategie von macron ja sozusagen in
Deutschland seine Größe seiner seiner
besonderen Verantwortung müsse auch
sehen wo die anderen bleiben natürlich
muss man das auch diskutieren das
passiert ja jetzt auf dem Gipfel aber
das Deutschland sahen Interessen
vertritt das heißt dafür sorgt durch
hoffentlich wirksame Maßnahmen das
deutsche Betriebe nicht pleite gehen und
die die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Deutschland ihre Gas- und Stromrechnung
mit Zukunft weiterhin bezahlen können
auch mit staatlicher Hilfe ist pure
Selbstverständlichkeit die anderen
machen das genauso macht das aber so
eine Haltung vor Bosson schwächt das
Europa Borussia gerade im Moment so
wichtig wäre da geeint auf also sich zu
präsentieren ich glaube es zeigt einfach
ein Problem was in vielen Feldern zu
finden ist dass man auf der einen Seite
die Idee des vereinten Europas hat was
zunehmend tiefer zusammenwachsen muss
gerade in Anbetracht der Situation die
wir in Russland haben aber natürlich
auch in anderen Regionen Blick nach
China mal im Hinterkopf
und das dann aber doch die nationalen
Interessen immer dazwischen kommen und
das ist so ein Tauziehen ist zwischen
diesen beiden Interessen und ich habe
für beide Interessen Verständnis das
Problem ist man muss ein Kompromiss
zwischen beiden finden und Deutschland
hat natürlich eine Sonderrolle weil es
weil es eben ein so starkes also auch
ökonomisch starkes Land ist so dieses zu
groß für Europa zu klein gefällt ein
bisschen und die Situation vor der Olaf
Scholz jetzt steht ist diese ja dieses
standing zu verwalten also er tritt da
mehr oder weniger in die Fußstapfen von
Angela Merkel hat aber ja in seinem
Regierungsstil auf einer deutschen
Autobahn gibt es das noch nicht aber in
seinem Regierungsstil scheint mir das
Tempolimit schon zu wirken ist ja jemand
der sehr langsam oder unmerklich agiert
und dann aber doch irgendwann mit einer
Lösung um die Ecke kommt also man könnte
sich auch vorstellen dass morgen Mittag
alles wieder ganz anders aussieht
rechnen Sie damit der Krause das ist
dann letztendlich alles wieder schön
abgeräumt ist
die Frage ist ja wie weit muss man sich
denn einigen überhaupt in dieser Frage
ich sehe da nur sehr begrenzte
Notwendigkeiten weil
also der Gedanke zum Beispiel dass wir
jetzt alle alle Gas Importunternehmen in
Europa ihr Geld an die Kommission
übergeben und dann kauft eine Behörde
für uns ein also da rollen sich mehr
alle Fußnägel auf denn dann kommt
Verträge dabei raus wie wir sie bei den
Impfstoffen gehabt haben die man sich
ziemlich schlimm sind dass man gemeinsam
Einkauf finden Sie nicht sinnvoll oder
so kann kathielle bilden aber das können
Sie jetzt schon wissen die das
interessant ist doch das das ist schon
jetzt erlaubt es ist nur kein Zwang dazu
da und all die Länder die das die danach
schreien machen es nicht warum wohl
kann man noch mal fragen die könnten das
machen Italien Frankreich Belgien
so sie machen es nicht hier ist
ausdrücklich ein Kartell erlaubt
Kartelle sonst verboten so und das und
und und und ich glaube eben einfach dass
es damit auch nichts zu machen ist ich
glaube auch dass das Bild nicht mehr
stimmt ich was sie gerade gezeigt
Deutschland lernt gerade dass es eben
nicht mehr dieses riesenreiche Land in
der Mitte Europas ist wir werden
Wohlstandsverluste hinnehmen müssen das
wird bei uns und das führt jetzt schon
zu zu ziemlich harten sozialen
Konflikten in unserer Gesellschaft
vielleicht in Ostdeutschland ein
bisschen deutlicher sichtbar als in
Westdeutschland
wir werden es nicht schaffen sie können
es ist schwerer übrigens auch falsch
aber wäre das nicht im Grund um die umso
mehr gemeinsam zu stehen in Europa und
Dinge also dass dieser gemeinsame
gaseinkommen
sinnvoll was machen wir denn dann
gemeinsam also noch mal wenn wenn das so
sinnvoll wäre gemeinsam Gas einzukaufen
warum machen es die die das fordern
nicht
ich sehe das nicht der lassen Sie doch
da auch Wettbewerb gelten das ist ist
doch in Ordnung der und und ich wir
werden wir werden noch genug andere
Dinge zu tun haben wir werden nicht jede
Gasrechnung ausgleichen können die jetzt
im nächsten Gesetz kommt doch alles erst
noch im nächsten Jahr wir dürfen es
übrigens auch nicht weil die Menschen
werden nicht weniger Gas verbrauchen
wenn wenn der Preis so ist wie früher
dann machen sie auch weiter wie bisher
so man muss sich dann eben halt
überlegen kann ich noch alle meine
Zimmer heizen auch noch den ganzen Tag
und so weiter ja ich glaube wir müssen
auch wenn wir diese Prozesse sehr sehr
nüchtern realitätsnah analysieren wollen
müssen wir uns davon lösen sozusagen die
scheinbar guten europäischen Interessen
den scheinbar weniger guten nationalen
Interessen gegenüberzustellen bitte so
ein bisschen sehr sehr nett von ihnen
formuliert in ihrem Beitrag angeklungen
ist wir werden Europa und die Einheit in
Europa in der Europäischen Union nur
bewahren und voranbringen können
momentan geht es ja nur noch darum sie
zu bewahren Europa driftet auseinander
wenn deutlich wird dass das eine
Vereinigung von souveränen Nationen zum
Wohle aller zum Wohle auch der einzelnen
Länder ist
das ist auch legitim die eigenen
Interessen zu vertreten so wie es
selbstverständlich sein sollte dass der
Bundeskanzler deutsche Interessen
vertritt in Brüssel das ist sein in der
Tat das ist sein Amtseid so ist es bei
allen anderen Regierungschefs auch
selbstverständlich das wird in den
anderen Ländern auch nicht hinterfragt
deutschland ist das einzige Land in dem
sich die Regierung immer schwer tut sich
klar dazu zu bekennen zunächst mal den
Job zu haben für das eigene Land und das
Wohl der eigenen Bürger zu kämpfen so
und dann setzt man sich zusammen
überlegt wo und wie kann man sich
verständigen ich bin auch ja ganz bald
raus ich glaube bei dieser bei dieser
gaspreisgeschichte wird das sehr sehr
schwer sein das wird auch Wettbewerb
eher unterdrücken aber wir haben doch
fundamental andere Fragen wo wir Europa
wieder zueinander bringen müssen die
Frage der Sanktionen gegenüber Russland
etwa die Frage wie wir den Laden
überhaupt
eine Sanktionen gegen Russlands sie sind
Präsident der deutsch-ungarischen
Gesellschaft warum ich würde gerne aber
bevor wir dazu kommen zu den Sanktionen
würde ich gerne mal Frau Selle noch mal
dazu zu Deutschlands Rolle haben dann
sonst kommen wir hier viel zu schnell
durcheinander wird noch mal gerne ihre
Position hören dazu also grausert wir
sind vielleicht dann nicht mehr so ein
großer Player da in der EU wie sehen sie
es denn und die sollte man mit dir mit
der jetzigen Krise wie sollte man dann
Deutschlands Rolle der anders definieren
also ich finde es ja schon es ist schön
dass sie so diese Dichotomie aufmachen
die nationalen Interessen und die
europäischen Interessen die sozusagen
gegeneinander stehen ich sehe das aus
der deutschen Perspektive
ist aber auch ähnlich für viele andere
Mitgliedstaaten aber insbesondere für
Deutschland können wir das europäische
nicht vom nationalen Interesse trennen
das können wir ökonomisch nicht trennen
und das können wir in einem großen Teil
auch gesellschaftlich nicht trennen wenn
es Europa schlecht geht geht es
Deutschland schlecht und umgekehrt und
diese diese Dichotomie aufzumachen was
ist unser nationales Interesse was es
unser europäisches Interesse ist aus
meiner Perspektive und komplett
umgedreht habe Blick auf wie europäische
Innenpolitik heute funktioniert wir
haben ein fundamentales Interesse in
Deutschland daran dass es unser Nachbarn
gut geht weil nur dann wird es uns gut
gehen wir sind Exportnationen Nummer
eins was unsere europäischen was
eigentlich alle europäischen Staaten
angeht wir haben ein fundamentales
Interesse daran dass es unseren Nachbarn
gut geht und das im übrigen auch beim
Thema
Gaseinkauf also ich sehe das schon
gewissen Scham drin ich sehe es auch
anders als Herr Krause damals die
Impfstoff
natürlich im rückwirkend reden wir über
hohe Preise aber am Ende war diese
europäische Solidarität der gemeinsamen
Einkauf eine extreme Hebel der gerade
beispielsweise die baltischen Staaten
kleinere Staaten denen überhaupt
Impfstoff verfügbar gemacht hat und
ähnlich sehe es auch beim beim
Gaseinkauf das ist natürlich momentan
Deutschland ob seiner Marktmacht da sehr
viel aufkauft und wenn man da sich sich
zusammenhält oder die beteiligten
Unternehmen wäre das sicherlich eine
gute gute Sache
aber ich finde einfach dieses national
versus europäisch also sorry da sind wir
irgendwie so ein Stück weit drüber weg
zumindest in Deutschland vorhin einmal
kurz selbst gesagt nur leider nicht
betont es kann noch keiner unserer
Nachbarn darin Interesse haben dass es
unserer Wirtschaft schlecht gibt geht
wenn hier in Deutschland die Dinge
zusammen richten dann kann ich Ihnen
sagen dann wird Europa wichtig bleiben
aber das heißt wenn hier gerade wir sind
im Moment in ziemlicher not um das mal
deutlich zu sagen und wenn sich unsere
Regierung jetzt in erster Linie erstmal
unser notwidmet dann tut sie damit etwas
für Europa das ist nicht gegen Europa
ich habe nicht gesagt dass ich gegen die
200 Milliarden bin ich bin ich sehe es
skeptisch wie man das kommuniziert hat
gegenüber unseren europäischen Partnern
ich bin nicht gegenüber gegen gegen die
Hilfen ich habe es ja gerade selber
gesagt nur wenn es Deutschland gut geht
kann es Europa gut gehen und umgekehrt
also ich finde man muss jetzt man muss
es wirklich konkretisieren das ist das
ist mir zu abstrakt alle sehen ihre
nationalen Interessen und wir müssen
jetzt diskutieren wie können wir im
Interesse aller einzelnen Länder etwas
Gemeinsames realisieren was ja in
letzten Monaten auch geklappt hat also
die Europäische Union hat ja im
wesentlichen eine gemeinsame Antwort auf
diesen schrecklichen russischen
Angriffskrieg gefunden wo jetzt gar
nicht unbedingt aber ich bitte Sie
Ungarn hat Ungarn hat sämtliche
sanktionspakete der Europäischen Union
mit unterstützt
am Ende sie haben sie haben es gemacht
sie haben da wo es lebensnotwendig war
auch Ausnahmen erkämpft wie andere
übrigens auch gucken Sie mal wer
momentan das ganze russische Öl nach
Indien transportiert das sind die
tankerflotten aus Griechenland aus
Zypern und aus Malta die haben sich fein
säuberlich Ausnahmen für diesen Öl für
diesen öltransportausbildung so also
alle vertreten ihre Interessen so Ungarn
hat Ungarn hat die sanktionspakete alle
mitgetragen hätte sie ja blockieren
können Ungarn hat aber auch gesagt wir
stehen fest an der Seite der Ukraine
aber wir werden unser Land nicht in den
Krieg hinein ziehen lassen und wir
werden und wir werden nicht zulassen
dass die ungarische Wirtschaft ruiniert
wird und dass die Menschen in Ungarn
ihre Wohnung nicht mehr heizen können
wenn das die Folge dieser Sanktionen
sein sollte also eigentlich
zu den Russland Sanktionen eigentlich
hat es die schon gegeben sie erinnern
sich vielleicht am 3 April waren
Parlamentswahlen in Ungarn als der
Ukraine Krieg schon lief und Viktor
Orban hat im Grunde genommen seine
Haltung im ukrainekrieg zentral zur
Abstimmung gestellt mit der klaren
Botschaft wir unterstützen die Ukraine
wir werden nichts unterstützen was zum
Ruin unseres eigenen Landes führt im
Grunde genommen ist das was jetzt in
Ungarn diskutiert wird auch in Europa
über die ungarische Position abgeleitet
aus dieser Grundhaltung glauben Sie mir
dass findet die Unterstützung der weit
überwiegenden Mehrheit des ungarischen
Volkes und ich gehen auch einen Schritt
weiter ich glaube dass die Diskussion
über die Sanktionen die Ungarn anstößt
auch bei uns längst überfällig ist und
ich prophezeihe ihn die Diskussion über
die Wirksamkeit der Sanktionen gegen
Russland wird bei uns auch in
Deutschland in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten noch eine Intensität erreichen
die sich mancher bisher noch nicht
vorstellen kann also wie eigentlich
immer was würden Sie dazu sagen die
eigentlich ist sich da Deutschland ist
das was Ungarn macht sind sie da
Vorreiter nein
ich finde findet der Ton in Ungarn ist
nun deutlich anreich meinen nehmen Sie
mal die Plakatkampagne die da gerade
läuft
wo wo wo wo wo sozusagen richtig
Stimmung gemacht wird auch gegen Brüssel
also ich sehe da Ungarn und Deutschland
überhaupt nicht in einem Boot leider
aber der
die Debatte über die Frage wie die wie
wirksam sind die Sanktionen und wie sehr
es schaden sie auch uns selbst
die haben wir ja längst nur nur machen
uns nichts vor wir haben das russische
Gas nicht weil wir es nicht kaufen
sondern Putin liefert es nicht so und
und das ist wenn man so will eine
gegensanktion die
irgendwelche Menschen haben die
Ostseepipeline in die Luft gejagt die
das heißt da kann gar nicht mehr das Gas
durchfließen was man fließend geflossen
ist
die die Wirksamkeit der Sanktionen gegen
in Russland ist unbestreitbar dies ist
massiv viel schlimmer die russische
Wirtschaft ist fast an der Erde die hat
ich meine die haben natürlich Rohstoffe
klar das haben sie immer gehabt aber das
ist alles sie müssen jetzt sie sind
nicht mehr in der Lage ihre Waffen zu
selbst zu produzieren sie müssen jetzt
immer Iran Drohnen kaufen
was der Iran zwar bestreitet aber
wenn wenn Drohnen aussehen wie iranische
Auswirkung der Sanktionen auf unser Land
der Krause das soll das sollten wir
machen ja gut aber ich sage es gibt es
gibt ja Leute
bei uns die die mit russischen Fahnen
durch die Straßen ziehen und
und und und und und die der Meinung sind
nichts das wichtiger als ihr warmes
Wohnzimmer ich glaube dass das die irren
weil ich glaube wenn man Putin nicht
Einhalt gibt dann dann sind wir die
nächsten ja angreifen wird und das hat
er oft genug erklärt und und das und und
jetzt wissen wir dass wir seine Worte er
ernst nehmen müssen ich habe das ja
früher auch nicht getan so und und und
ich glaube das natürlich
Sanktionen Schaden immer auch der
eigenen Wirtschaft das ist doch geil gar
keine Frage die andere Deutschland hat
früher mit den Rahmen super Geschäfte
gemacht aber die Zahlen sprechen
einander Sprache vielleicht können wir
das kleine aber so wie würden Sie denn
dieses Abwägen von National europäischem
Interesse und dann halt eben auch die
Frage von wie sehr müssen wir schauen ob
die Sanktionen uns schaden oder halt
eben Russland schauen die wie sehen sie
diese meine Verhältnismäßigkeit und ich
glaube es gibt keine
das wollte ich gerade gratis Mentalität
sagen aber Freiheit gibt es nicht zum
Nulltarif und es kann nicht sein dass
wir auf der einen Seite sagen in der
Ukraine werden unsere Werte verteidigt
aber nicht bereit sind auch nur einen
Schritt der Ukraine entgegenzugehen und
ich glaube die Sanktionen die jetzt
beschlossen sind sind da gebe ich Ihnen
recht definitiv schädlicher für Russland
wir werden kein Sanktionspaket bekommen
was wir überhaupt nicht spüren außerhalb
gegrillt uns gleich noch seinen
Vorschlag dazu
aber es ist was ist also dass ich
verstehe einfach diese die diesen
Glauben nicht so ganz dass man ein Krieg
mitten in Europa hat indem es um so viel
geht nämlich um die Integrität eines
Landes um die Integrität von
europäischen Werten und um die Frage ob
am Ende die Demokratie oder die
Autokratie am längeren Hebel sitzt
und man dann sagt man möchte es aber nur
so lange mitspielen bis wir irgendwas
merken natürlich müssen wir gucken dass
das und das ob das jetzt der doppelbums
ist oder oder auf europäischer Ebene
natürlich muss man schauen dass es die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht so sehr
belastet dass es wirklich zu sozialen
Sprengstoff führt aber trotzdem glaube
ich dass ein ein gar nichts spüren eine
Illusion ist wir müssen aber doch wir
müssen mit den Fakten Arbeiten es gibt
sehr seriöse Berechnung unabhängiger
Forschungsinstitute die besagen dass
Russland in Zeitraum seit Beginn des
Krieges bis etwa Ende August ca 160
Milliarden Euro an export erlösen
erzielt hat nur durch den Export von
fossilen Energieträgern das sind
Rekordeinnahmen wenn sie sich mal die
Entwicklung des Rubel anschauen dann wir
bedauern das sicherlich alle damit da
kein kein Vertun gibt ja aber die die
Ankündigungen von Frau Programm Anfang
die Sanktionen werden Russland ruinieren
Frau von der Leyen wir werden die
russische Wirtschaft Stück für Stück
abtragen das hat so nicht funktioniert
und das ist jetzt kein Widerspruch zu
dem was sie so nicht festgestellt haben
so und natürlich wird man langfristig
damit die russische Wirtschaft
bestätigen aber das rohstoffreichste
Land der Welt mit solchen Sanktionen in
die Knie zwingen zu wollen und letztlich
dazu zu bewegen darum geht es doch
diesen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine zu
beenden das klappt nicht und deshalb ist
der ist der Hinweis der ungarischen
Regierung richtig es wird Zeit dass auf
den Prüfstand zu stellen und sich
präziser zu überlegen mit welchen
Maßnahmen können wir den Krieg beenden
können wir zumindest einen
Waffenstillstand herbeiführen das wird
doch niemand mehr glauben wir sind jetzt
Mitte Oktober dass wir mit den
Sanktionen Putin dazu bewegen werden den
den den Krieg einzusetzen
und im übrigen glaube ich auch dass die
Situation in der wir heute sind ist
natürlich zu einem großen Teil
aufgrund des russischen angriffskriegs
auf die Ukraine gekommen aber wir dürfen
auch nicht vergessen wir hatten vorher
schon Inflation wir hatten vorher schon
also wir haben sozusagen eine Krise die
sich oder Krisen die sich kumuliert
haben also das jetzt monokausal die Lage
in der wir jetzt sind auf die Sanktionen
gegen Russland zu schieben sorry das ist
echt ein bisschen kurz gesprungen es ist
auch also ich will ihnen übrigens noch
mal Widersprechendes sie haben völlig
Recht die der russische Staat hat aus
seinen energieexporten Rekordeinnahmen
erzielt stimmt das reicht aber nicht für
Russland auch die Russen wollen Autos
fahren auch die Russen wollen Computer
haben auch die Russen wollen
medizinische Geräte haben und dafür
fehlen ihnen jetzt die die Teile die
Ersatzteile
das wird ich will ihnen sagen das
schädigt die russische zum Beispiel die
russische Waffen ist massiv geschädigt
der Iran wird Gründe haben warum er das
nicht zugeben will dass er in Russland
drohen liefert der das ist ein Teil
davon die russische Wirtschaft ist
massiv geschädigt und natürlich sie
haben Recht auch uns
würde das Lasten auf so die Frage ist
was was denn sonst wir haben es
wissend
EU und auf das was das Thema unserer
Sendung eigentlich ist weil sonst reden
wir die ganze Zeit über Sanktionen und
die Ukraine und das eigentlich ist unser
Thema ja die Frage ob diese Gemeinschaft
der EU jetzt irgendwie zerbröckelt durch
all die großen Krisen die wir haben ob
das eigentlich ein zu großes zu große
Aufgabe ist und der Bundeskanzler hat
sich heute in seiner Regierungserklärung
zu diesem EU-Gipfel hat er hat er gesagt
die Ukraine Deutschland und die EU
werden geeinter und unabhängiger aus
dieser Bewährungsprobe hervorgehen als
zuvor also das klang ja sehr
zuversichtlich ist es naiv
zuversichtlich Frau Welle oder was
denken sie dass er da so zufällig naja
historisch betrachtet hat er ja schon
recht also in der Vergangenheit hat
haben Krisen immer dazu geführt dass man
am Ende durch
viele europäische Gipfel oder viele
europäische Nachtsitzungen der Staats-
und Regierungschefs man am Ende stärker
war das war in der Euro und
Staatsschuldenkrise so auch wenn wir da
immer noch ein paar Probleme haben das
war auch wenn wir jetzt auf die
corona-pandemie blicken und ich habe
natürlich und ich bin Optimistin ich
hoffe auch dass das zu einem Moment wird
wo Europa gerade in der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit und in der Frage
können wir wollen wir wirklich mal
diesen sprungwagen ein geopolitischer
Akteur zu werden Frau Bosson hat eben
schon China angesprochen also wir drehen
uns wir schauen sehr auf uns und
natürlich
die Welt dreht sich weiter und ich
glaube oder ich hoffe sehr dass das auch
so ein Impuls setzen wird der
Bundeskanzler hatte ja auch gesagt diese
Idee eines europäischen
luftabwehrschirmes den er in Prag
vorgestellt hat da haben sich
mittlerweile 14 Staaten angeschlossen
also ich glaube dass man einfach auch
stärker flexibel agieren muss gerade in
der Außenpolitik was ja auch immer noch
ein sehr sensibles Feld ist und dass man
hier auch stärker auf Koalition
derjenigen Staaten setzen kann und muss
die Fake und willens und in der Lage
sind das auch zu machen und dann kann
Europa auch mehr Schritte vorangehen wie
sehen sie ist diese Zuversicht die herr
Scholz da heute im Bundestag verbreitet
hat zurecht oder sehen Sie es negative
also weniger optimistisch hätte ich an
seiner Stelle stehen müssen hätte ich es
vielleicht auch so formuliert aber ich
stehe jetzt hier oder sind sie hier ich
kann etwas kritischer oder etwas
pessimistischer draften ich glaube
Flexibilität ist jetzt nicht gerade so
die ganz große Stärke von Europa und
gerade was Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik
angeht also wenn man sich anschaut also
was Europa eigentlich bräuchtet um
wirklich abwehrbereit zu sein
und wann das denn dann überhaupt fertig
produziert ist wann das einsatzbereit
ist wann die Soldaten und Soldate denn
ausgebildet sind um das Ganze auch zu
bedienen also da sind Zeitabschnitte da
kann Herr März sagen im Frühjahr ist mit
dem Winterreifen zu spät das ist dann
eher ich weiß gar nicht da was was da
jetzt für ein Bild passen würde aber
ich glaube da sind auch deutlich andere
Abschnitte die die wir noch gar nicht
überblicken können und noch einmal auf
auf China also das ist ja eigentlich das
sowieso vor unserer Augen stehendes
wachsende Problem was passiert
eigentlich wenn wir ein vergleichbare
Situation mit China haben und es ist
vermutlich nicht besonders klug eine
Abhängigkeit von einem autokratischen
Land mit dem wir in einem militärischen
Konflikt auch indirekt kommen können
weiter auszubauen also jetzt nur mit
Blick auf den Hamburger Hafen aber
daraus müsste man noch wenigstens lernen
dass man dass man diese einseitige
Abhängigkeit nicht wiederholt und die
haben wir ja zu China schon in einigen
Punkten dass man die weiter zurückbaut
das ist doch jetzt etwas was wirklich
dringend und notwendig ist und würde
dafür sprechen dass man dass ich Europa
da stärker als stärker präsentiert
zusammenarbeitet in dem Punkt ich glaube
dass wir in der Tat seit Beginn des
kriege ich sehr viel erreicht haben dass
Europa dennoch sich in einer
Europäischen Union ums zu konkretisieren
sich in einer sehr sehr gefährlichen
Phase befindet denn wir sehen das wenn
wir uns sozusagen dass das binnenleben
der Europäischen Union anschauen wie die
Staaten auseinanderdriften und das hat
Gründe die wir ernst nehmen müssen ein
Grund ist eine zunehmende Tendenz zu
einem Brüsseler Zentralismus
unabhängig von der politischen Couleur
in Brüssel sind sich alle Akteure einig
ob Kommission Parlament das EuGH am Ende
des Tages auch sie wollen mehr und mehr
Kompetenzen nach Brüssel verlagern und
viele Länder in Europa sehen das sehr
sehr kritisch insbesondere die
visegrad-staaten die Mittel- und
osteuropäischen Länder der Europäischen
Union das sind alles überzeugte Europäer
sie wollen nur nicht dass in Brüssel
entschieden wird wie die Ungarn oder die
Polen ihre Kinder ihre Kinder erzielen
Europa Stärken Herr Papke wenn ich die
Institutionen Schwäche nein ich muss ich
muss Europa wieder vom Kopf auf die Füße
stellen der der wunderbare
Einigungsprozess und Entstehungsprozess
der Europäischen Gemeinschaften und dann
der Europäischen Union seit den 50er
Jahren fußter auf der Überzeugung dass
es sich um die um die freiwillige
Zusammenarbeit souveräner Nationen zum
wohler aller halten würde es war nie es
war nie die Rede von einem europäischen
Zentralstaat einem europäischen
Superstaat der mehr und mehr Kompetenzen
ja aber es gibt natürlich diese
zentralisierungstendenz in Brüssel
selbstverständlich gibt es die wenn wir
nüchtern über Europa
wir haben jetzt mitten in der Krise gibt
es gibt es neue Verfahren gegen Polen
und Ungarn ja so obwohl die Ungarn
bereit sind beim Thema
Rechtsstaatlichkeit hat die ungarischer
Nationalversammlung viele Forderungen
aufgegriffen dennoch gibt es gibt es den
Vorschlag 7,5 Milliarden Euro an Ungarn
zustehenden Zuwendung zu kürzen in einer
Situation in der die Geschlossenheit der
Europäer nötiger wäre denn je ja da geht
es um eine Machtfrage weshalb wird gegen
Polen und vor allem gegen Ungarn
gearbeitet weil das Länder sind sich das
noch sagen darf die sich dem Brüsseler
Zentralismus entgegenstellen und da ging
es sich Zentralismus sondern um sie
müssen wir müssen die Machtfrage im
Hintergrund sehen und das sind Dinge die
man miteinander besprechen muss da muss
Deutschland auch eine mittlere Rolle
übernehmen ich bedauere das sehr dass es
momentan nicht um Zentralismus bei
diesen Fragen sonst geht darum halten
sich Ungarn Polen an das was sie selbst
mal unterschrieben haben freiwillig
ungezwungen als sie beigetreten sind und
nur darum geht es halten Sie sich an die
Standards zu denen sie sich verpflichtet
haben tun sie im Moment beide nicht und
deswegen gibt es die Verfahren
gefährlich das fest ob sie das tun oder
nicht bitte wer legt das denn fest ob
sie das tun
die Europäische Kommission sie haben
also der Europäische Gerichtshof hat die
letzte Entscheidung auch das haben die
beiden Länder mal unterschrieben als sie
der EU beigetreten sind und nicht
richtig doch das war der ag-kommunion
es geht ja um den Zusammenhalt Europas
und und
ich war ja hier schon ein paar Mal zu
Gast ich bin bedauere seit langem dass
dass wir nicht getunt genug getan haben
um das an Auseinanderdriften der
Europäischen Union
wenigstens abzubremsen wenn ich zufällig
wir haben ganz viel zugelassen damit das
was wir uns mal unter EU vorgestellt
haben damit das langsam zerbröseln
konnte heute und da ist dann wieder
meine Zuversicht wird die EU
zusammengehalten durch vielleicht das
beste Mittel das es gibt nämlich den
Egoismus der Mitgliedstaaten es gibt
kein Mitgliedstaat der das Gefühl hat
ich bin besser dran bin ich rausgehe die
Briten haben das gedacht und erleben das
eindrucksvoll dass es nicht so ist
übrigens auch jetzt
die war nämlich den Wirkung der Märkte
ausgesetzt mit ihrer komischen
Steuerpolitik bei uns wird macht die EZB
alle möglichen Leute
zusammenhält ist das wir wissen
ja das funktioniert so und die und nun
wissen wir der Egoismus der
Mitgliedstaaten führt dazu dass wir
sagen aha wir müssen uns wahrscheinlich
doch auch militärisch ein bisschen mehr
Wappen denn wir müssen wehrhafter werden
als wir es bisher war und wir können
nicht immer nur dass das Kuscheltierchen
da
in der Weltpolitik sein und und und
vielleicht kann das eine ganz
vernünftige Basis sein für für die
Zukunft
erleben dass eben auch ein Land viel
Deutschland und da muss ich vor und Frau
Bosson auch nochmal zu Wort kommen
lassen
genau ich möchte gerne auf den
Zusammenhalt auch noch mal kommen und
glaube schon und das sollte auch eine
Lehre sein der letzten Monate die wir
gerade als Deutschland die auch
Frankreich sehr ernst nehmen muss dass
wir nämlich den Mittel osteuropäischen
Staaten lange nicht zugehört haben in
Fragen ihrer unmittelbaren Bedrohungen
gegenüber Russland und das ist was was
wir als Deutschland sehr sehr ernst
nehmen müssen
und was wir glaube ich auch aufarbeiten
müssen also dass wir Polen gesagt haben
jetzt stellt euch mal nicht so an
nordstromissen wirtschaftliches Projekt
und die baltischen Staaten Polen haben
da immer gesagt warum macht ihr das es
ist gegen unsere Sicherheitsinteressen
und Deutschland hat es ignoriert und ich
glaube und ich glaube dass
ist einfach ein ganz ganz wichtiger
Punkt dass wir da im Grunde diesen
diesen Zusammenhalt auch wieder stärken
und Deutschland auch einfach wieder auch
um Vertrauen werben muss und ich finde
das gehört auch zu diesem Gesamtpaket
dazu auch wieder sterben sehen Sie denn
da eine Möglichkeit gerade mit Polen und
Ungarn ist es ja dann doch also ich
würde da auch Polen und Ungarn nicht
nicht gleichsetzen ich sehe dass und das
sieht auch im übrigen Polen nicht mehr
so also der ukrainerkrieg hat schon sehr
oder der russische Angriffskrieg hat
sehr deutlich gezeigt wie isoliert
Ungarn auch im wischegrad und und in
Mitteleuropa ist
und dass das da gerade Polen auch
einfach wieder
eine sehr andere Rolle auch durchaus
eingenommen hat und wir haben die
Probleme die herr Krause eben gen hat
und die müssen die dürfen darf man jetzt
nicht hinten anstellen aber wir müssen
trotzdem anerkennen dass wir nicht
zugehört haben und ich glaube das ist
auch ein so eine Lehre dass wir da mehr
hingucken müssen mehr hinfahren müssen
und mehr miteinander reden müssen ich
würde gerne zum Schluss die
Schriftstellerin mit einem Zitat von
einem anderen Schriftsteller noch mal
konfrontieren Gerd mag der
niederländische Schriftsteller hat
gesagt viele Leute aus der Generation
von Scholz ist Europa etwas
geschäftliches nicht der Garant von
Frieden aber europa verliert etwas wenn
es nur als etwas geschäftliches gesehen
wird wie sehen sie es denn
ich glaube das ist vielleicht auch die
Aufgabe von von Publizistinnen um es mal
ein bisschen weiterzufassen natürlich
muss Europa eine Erzählung haben die
mehr ist als das Bruttoinlandsprodukt
das ist einfach nichts was Menschen
zusammenschweißt jetzt haben wir einen
Krieg das ist eine sehr tragische Form
Menschen zusammen zu schweißen das ist
keine die ich mir wünsche
aber das was wir schon haben und da sind
wir dann doch wieder bei den
Blick auf Ungarn ist es auch eine
Wertegemeinschaft und da muss man schon
schauen wenn gegen die Werte verstoßen
wird dann kann man das nicht einfach
unkommentiert hinnehmen und ich würde
Ihnen noch mal wirklich beipflichten
wollen natürlich haben wir oder wir also
ob jetzt aus Deutschland oder als
gesamte EU zu wenig auf osteuropäische
Länder und aus Stimmen von dort auch
gehört wir hätten auch sehr gut auf
osteuropäische Autoren und Autorinnen
hören können die alle oder sehr sehr
viele nicht alle aber sehr sehr viele
davor gewarnt haben ob das jetzt Litauen
Polen oder oder sonst wo ist und das ist
glaube ich wirklich ein großes
Versäumnis gewesen und da muss man
zukünftig wenn man in die Zukunft guckt
also auf wo muss man jetzt genau
hinhören ich glaube man muss mehr auf
die Peripherie hören oder man muss
unterschiedliche Stimmen aus der
Peripherie aufnehmen
ernst zu nehmen was diese völkerkleinern
Völker Europas wollen zuhören zuhören
und kann nicht nur heißen man hört sich
das an und macht dann doch das was die
großen Länder wollen
es gibt sehr Spieler aus der ungarischen
Zivilgesellschaft die eine ganz andere
demokratisch legitim Ministerpräsident
richtig beschrieben der hat nicht nur
ein geschäftlichen Blick auf Europa
vielen dank ihnen wir sind natürlich
noch lange nicht am Ende dieser
Diskussion aber am Ende dieser Phönix
Runde vielen Dank Frau Seele Herr Papke
herr Krause und Frau Bosson für diese
Diskussion vielen dank ihnen fürs
Interesse und sie werden natürlich
weiter auf dem laufenden gehalten über
den EU-Gipfel denn jetzt geht's weiter
bei Phoenix der Tag und das moderiert
mein Kollege Stefan Kulle bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]